[Music]
yep
yes oh my god what an embarrassing intro
that was
hello everybody welcome back to another
episode of the unwaxed podcast with your
baby sister
sophia and steve stallone you know
that's starting to grow on me yay
on that back let's try it again no it's
good
um i'm happy it's growing on you i think
it works it just it kind of flows and i
get it
it gets me hammed and yes she is
tweaking it's just one of them days
you're singing though all right let's
move on um
this has been a very interesting week
for sophia and i we feel like a lot of
strange reoccurrences have happened
yep and you know we have been mentioning
it to each other but now
it's hit a wall okay so we're all about
manifestation and
for example i'll be driving into a
parking garage i'll manifest a parking
spot and then it'll happen right
but we've been manifesting this is going
to sound so pathetic
a friend so
lately sistine has been visualizing
things and then getting them
i've been seeing 11 11 everywhere at
night and morning now i think i'm just
like clockwork i know when it's 11 11
but it's weird
so cece and i've been talking since
we've come to florida
that we've been wanting a friend i love
her
she loves me but you know
we need a bit we need a third we need a
third party to sort of break it up
yes and so we've been saying to each
other that we've been
dying to meet someone new yeah here in
florida
we know we know no one and so it's it's
definitely hard being away from your
friends in l.a
so we went to dinner the other night we
were manifesting at dinner we were like
we gotta find a friend yeah we decide
let's go get a drink sofia lo and behold
we go to the bar
we don't do this ever we see a girl
sitting alone at the bar
yeah two hours later bffs
friend and guess what we're getting
dinner with her tonight
how did the coincidence i think not
another coincidence is i've been having
a lot of weird dreams and i want to
bring on a dream specialist because i
truly believe
that when you have something traumatic
happen in your dream it
applies to your regular what day-to-day
life and traumatic in your life just
been having
very gruesome
explicit gory dreams it's really sad
but here's the weird part i've been
dreaming about individuals that i've
never met in my life
never think about in my life i don't
watch any of their content
and then they'll be showing up the next
day in my life like for example
go ahead i had a dream about dave
portnoy oh
do i follow dave portney no do i follow
barstool
no i don't ever talk or locate that no
it
is not in our purpose why was i dreaming
of him we'll get to that later
i go hey dad i had a dream about dave
portnoy and he goes
oh that's so interesting i was on the
phone with him today
what that's my point you guys we're
stuck is this deja vu
is it 2021 is something going on this
year
that's been changing and making us
because it's been happening we've
mentioned a name
and they'd come up somewhere else maybe
in the news it's just like happening a
lot
it's baffling but it's kind of making
things interesting what is the property
this is deja vu what is the actual
definition of deja vu no okay so deja vu
what i've come to gather is when you
have an experience
and you feel like you've done that
before so i can't tell if it's that
or if it's just we're psychic
i think i think what the psychic said we
have spiritual powers
so now we're able to predict the future
so if you guys want
your future read by sophia nice to see
you
you know what actually could be it just
came to me yeah i think we've been
thinking very weird thoughts because you
sort of
dragged me into your love of anime you
guys sophia's been watching a lot of
anime
um well yes nothing against anime but i
just did not peg you as the type
to watch it i did not peg myself as the
type to watch anime but
i'll tell you how it happened my little
sister scarlett she's into it
yeah she loves it but she kind of
secretly liked it she told us she was
into it we didn't realize like the
extent of it
and what do you like about it well this
is what my thing was so i was kind of
curious because i saw there was a
netflix series that came out
that they made it's called like coco
guri or something it's about community i
don't know what it's called
but i was like you know what i'm gonna
just just check it out i'm gonna check
it out very sexual
and it's it's so sexual like it's so
sexual you guys it doesn't
there are things in the show that i
didn't
think would happen you know it was one
of those like huge plot twists every
single time it was like why did they
just do that
you know this is a whole genre of porn
what is it called it's like
it's all anime well it's very sexual it
was a very
sexual show but it's so interesting the
show honestly i got weirdly addicted to
it
i haven't watched any anime since i've
been like dabbling a little bit i don't
know if i could watch 24 7.
yeah but i definitely want to be one of
those characters for halloween
so you guys have to actually message us
some good suggestions yes
we don't like to we don't like to like
battles
we're trying to be cool we're trying to
be with gen z tick talkers we're trying
to be in the know
you do have a cowboy d pop shirt and
you've never seen cowboy dpop so maybe
thanks for outing me but you should
watch it it's anime
i don't know you can actually wear it i
know okay what else wait no
we're giving you all life updates you
guys we need to talk about um
what just happened the other day with
our lovely nails i know no one's
everyone's saying oh i don't want to
hear about your nails
no no you're going to want to hear about
this because i really like how you set
the scene
yeah i am not a nail slam snob
not i'm not a doorknob she's a knock
door knob but she's not
i'm not a nail snob i'm not kidding you
the last time i got my nails done
was a year ago this was before the
pandemic i just never got them done i
was like i'm not gonna waste the money i
could just do them myself i know how to
put on polish
right so i never got them done myself no
i was always actually kind of on the
nail shelf i'd say
i am very particular about how my nails
are shaped how they're cared for i just
think nails
people see your hands all the time i
know i just don't care i i just don't
care
um also i've heard guys actually do
check out your nails i know i know so i
go
i get my nails done i'm excited scarlett
our little sister
says you should get this thing called
dip i have no idea what this is
apparently it's acrylic powder
i don't know i go okay i'll try it she
goes you should do the shape
i'm balls the wall let's go for it
right i sit down i'm feeling optimistic
the girl and i are chatting away it's
great
and then i look down at my nails and
it looks like someone cut off my index
finger blood
a that
this this in this business reached out
to sistine and said like we'll
we'd love to do your nails and they do
dip and i've never done dip either and
that was like
situations so kind of crazy i'm like
they're dipping my fingers in powder and
it's turning into polish
and sistine's across the way and this
woman i just hear her
freaking out so i'm i'm sitting there
this girl is freaking out she keeps
jumping up out of her chair she can't
sit for more than five seconds
blood is i'm not exaggerating rushing
down my arm
the owner is freaking out because
apparently she was cutting my cuticles
like
really deep and i said when he's done
those cuticles and she was like almost
doing it with a blindfold on she's going
crazy so i'm bleeding everywhere and it
won't stop
and so i'm trying to be as polite as
possible i'm not freaking out i'm just
sitting there like no no it's okay
it's my fault like i don't know why i
can't stop bleeding that's what i'm
saying
because she was so upset i felt bad and
i felt really bad for her and then she
goes to me and the owner goes
are you anemic and i go i don't think so
and she goes
maybe you have diabetes that's why i
won't stop bleeding and i go
okay maybe i go to the doctor after this
check of my anemic
you didn't just split her skin in half
she had a vein
she kind of hit her you guys that's how
bad it is so this is jeans gushing blood
my nail polish on the other hand i
remember a nail polish that was so
thick on your nail like just like you
could literally see there
it looks like baby fingers but i just
have like claws like beautiful real
nails
she chopped that off and just layered my
nail
more little scissors more of the story
is if you can do it better yourself
do it yourself because don't go to
places that was a big fat mistake again
i love a bad story because i can bring
it on on wax so i'm here for the contest
perfect
at the end of the day you know save you
money
we decided uh we're gonna do something a
little bit different before we bring on
our guests today we're gonna
start with our unsolicited device
instead of ending the episode with it
just a quick reminder make sure you go
to our podcast page
at the apple podcast app leave your
question
in the comments and reviews section and
that is the only way
we are going to read or answer it if
it's less than five stars and you still
wrote an answer or question
we're not answering not cool not cool
and by the way
i read a lot of the dms and elite a lot
of the reviews that you guys leave and a
lot of them are saying
i know you'll never see this but i
really love you guys blah blah blah blah
and i'm sitting there in bed like i see
it we see
it we see it we don't see it we see it
so i really appreciate
hearing your guys's feedback it honestly
makes this so worth it and so much fun
so let's jump right into the question
619 hawk
wrote where do you guys see each other
in 10 years
what would you like to accomplish great
show thank you
ten years sophia i want to be none of
each other
each other where do you see each other
so stop answering ladies i i see you in
10 years
[Music]
you'll be married to a thomas shelby
singing songs like duolippa oh my god i
love doing that
um hold on i don't sing and he's married
so this is already over two times
um oh you released the film that you
wrote
she did sell a film that would be cool
and it actually comes out so then she's
now
a famous screenwriter like phoebe waller
bridge
and first woman not first woman to be on
the moon but like also live on the moon
i don't want to go to the moon
it scares me i don't want to do that no
no
no okay but we can't race all right you
would be
are you 24. you're going to be 34. whoa
34. 34 year old sophia will be sitting
alone at a bar
[Laughter]
you're married sure you've got one baby
yes probably maybe you have another one
in the stomach but you don't know it yet
yeah you're traveling with your husband
i'll price ski we're talking about today
34 like yesterday yeah
you guys are maybe like skiing you're
doing a honeymoon romantic vacation
because you're taking a break from your
busy schedule being the next oprah
winfrey i mean you're swapped
swamped you're like the ellen 2.0 right
you're just tired of giving away you get
a car you get a car
i'm tired of selling you know number one
book sellers
you know of all time and you're you're
just exhausted
uncovered forbes sometimes this is my
future stop
the stop i love this you're getting
carried away
but then she doesn't realize
that while she's on her honeymoon she's
totally unplugged right
off her phone she's trying to detox
she doesn't realize that her entire
business has been sued
you're getting sued you're being super
copyright
you're being sued for for being
ugly and you're pissed you've been
sued for giving away fake
cars oh okay so now
because they're actually now go carts
you don't realize all of this is
happening you don't realize
the empire that you've built is
crumbling down because you're just
drinking a pina colada
minding your own business you have no
idea what's going on in the states
you don't you don't even know that
that's why you're cancelled
because you're drinking your food but
everyone else knows that i don't know
so this is what happened to return yes
this is still
34 years today you return
you decide you know what this life isn't
for me
no you move okay connecticut yeah
you go to connecticut movie their
husband raise the families
have a chicken coop and one cow
wow it really took a turn anyway we
should talk about our guests today that
we're having on
take it away sophia you guys we have
the hilarious claudia oshery coming on
and if you guys don't know who she is
you will soon she is the host
of the widely popular morning toast
podcast she is a comedian
we'll do her a whole little intro later
but she is
we've never met her and i've watched
some interviews with her i've listened
to her podcast i've stalked her page so
many times we're
very excited she's funny yeah we're
gonna have some fun conversations she's
here to promote her book so
stay tuned meme queen and host of the
very popular podcast alongside her
sister the morning toast
this comedian entertainer and media
entrepreneur is now
coming out with her new book called girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an
instagram thirst monster this is
claudia oshery hi hi hey guys
did i say your name seeing sister yes
you did say my name right even though
it's like an interpretation whatever you
want to call me it's okay
um i just love going on podcasts hosted
by sisters because i host mine with my
sister and there's nothing better
i'm just gonna bring that up too because
we love the idea of working with the
sister and there's so many like ups and
downs with it but like
i mean did you guys ever fight in the
beginning of developing your podcast
well yeah i mean we don't really fight
but a lot of people are like how do you
work with your sister all the time and
i'm like how do you work with strangers
all the time like right
yeah i think it's so much easier to
communicate i'm not very confrontational
even though people like
i give off the vibe that i'm
confrontational because i'm like loud
and annoying
but i actually am very
anti-confrontation so like whatever
jackie thinks is right i'm like sure
yeah like let's just do what you want
i'll see
you that would be you're smarter than me
she's smarter than me and i know that
what are you what's your sign i'm a
cancer
and she's she's a cancer and she's a
scorpio i think november
i'm a virgo okay so that i kind of can
see that see it
the balance the dynamic does work
because there are things that she does
that really works for the show in terms
of like the more emotional part and
things
yeah i'm more of the analytics but we do
butt heads
if i say let's go right she'll go left
and then there's no no compromise
there's still good yeah but it's so much
easier to like butt heads with your
sister than like a stranger who you have
to be nice to like that's why i feel
like
working with your sister sort of the
same thing as having another roommate
i'd rather live with my sister than a
stranger because then you can't
say you know you didn't do the dishes or
your
clothes are all over the place like that
yeah insane
no and i'm sure you like have friends
and like i know people in my life who
are like really good communicators like
if something's bothering them they'll
say it in an eloquent way where it's
like if something's bothering me and i
get the balls to say it i'll just start
crying like
i'm not a good communicator
oh you're such a crying cancer then yeah
oh and i'm a cancer
to a t like tough exterior but like on
the inside i'm
dying and i'm so sad all the time but
like on that i feel
everyone's emotions you're sad i'm sad
now yeah yeah
i i'm not like really into horoscopes
but i know that i actually really
identify with my particular sign
yeah yeah so so do we and sometimes we
get like we like to have fun and get
into it but obviously we can't like
everything's kind of the same like if i
read someone else's horoscope i'm like
i've had those days before
100 like i think that sometimes
horoscopes can actually be toxic
because like you read something in a
magazine and then it substantiates your
negative behavior and it's like
no no it's not your it's not your your
sign you're just like an [ __ ]
like karen you're not just like having
an off day because the sun is blocking
them right and you're just no this is
you
this is you you you can change it too
you don't have to be
you can stop being but so it was kind of
interesting we read that you
are one of four girls yeah yeah because
we're one of we're
well there's three of us so all girls
so you're sort of the middle child
self-diagnosed middle child syndrome
yeah i was gonna say middle child
syndrome me hello
i mean you really like out of three like
that's hardcore middle child
but here's the thing i don't think i
ever got lack of attention i think
that's what the
correct definition of it is yeah i
always craved
more of it like i would i was very shy i
want to know how you sort of
were grew up because i was very shy when
i was little like crippling anxiety shy
oh reeling like don't hug me i'd be like
like i don't know it was like very bad i
was like the oldest being like so
nurtured so loved so i was like on the
stage and now i'm busy
i just want to be like the loudest the
funniest the one on the table like
you know self-deprecating to make people
laugh like how are you when you
grew up where you always like i mean
that's exactly how i am
now and in the book like i really i
never really like think about my
childhood a lot i just like
was a child and now i'm an adult but
with the book i had to like write down
because people always ask me like how i
grew up so many sisters
and my dad passed away when i was really
young so i wanted to like give away give
like a
tell a story about who i am and like why
i'm this crazy [ __ ] and when i look
back on my life like i'm exactly the
same like when i was a kid i was a nut
job i wanted attention so badly i would
sing i would dance i would do anything
for attention
all the adults thought i was annoying
and the adults still think i'm annoying
so
i'm consistent i'm consistent you're
like hey at least
you know what you're getting at this
point oh and like at least i make a
living out of being annoying you know
you know what it works it works and i
have to say the title of your book is
absolutely hilarious
thank you instagram thirst monster can
you define what that is
well i feel like in this age we're
living in with like the bachelor
um thirsting is has a negative
connotation
and i totally get it and i've definitely
been a part of you know the culture of
you know putting people down who are
thirsty but the more i look inward i'm
like
no i literally got to where i am like i
have a book deal because i'm thirsty
and yeah thirsty is so negative when at
the end of the day people who are
thirsty are just
good at networking you know i'm a good
networker so timing is is really
everything and now i feel like i've been
through
a lot in the last few years very public
lots of scandals lots of controversy
everyone loves that
um and i never really respond to stuff i
feel like
it's really hard for me to talk about it
because like i said i'm not
conversational like if i just start
talking about stuff i'll cry like that
is my mo i just yeah
and on my podcast i'm very off the cuff
you know my comedy is very i wing a lot
of stuff and it's not always
written you know that thoughtfully and
it doesn't have that much meaning behind
it so like
sitting down and taking the time to
actually think before i speak
and write something more eloquent and
like this is my side of the story right
you know i just thought it was important
i think the book is the perfect platform
for that like i don't think my podcast
is the perfect platform for that
i don't think my instagram or my comedy
is a perfect place for that so i think a
book was like a place for me to slow
down
and just like talk from beginning to end
that's exciting that's awesome because
now that people are gonna
see another side of you that maybe is
more vulnerable because like it's hard
to have a very funny confident exterior
24 7. i mean even on the show
we're always like coming into the show
going okay we gotta get like amp up
energy
and it's a lot of energy and then
sometimes there's something
not i know and then when you when you
become successful for being a funny
person like
everyone just like they almost treat you
like a zoo animal like you meet them and
they're like be funny
and i'm like i'm out to dinner can i
relax you know yeah
it's a lot of pressure it's a lot it's a
lot of pressure and also
people are always looking like if you're
especially if you're a woman in comedy
people are like well are you depressed
like what happened in your childhood and
it's like no i'm actually a woman in
comedy because i'm funny and like that's
what i wanted to do if i was smart i
would have become a doctor like
this is what i was born with and that's
what i do um but i think like after
reading the book and just getting to
know like
my obsession with pop culture and my
obsession with entertainment
um it's so clear like from day one like
obsessed with
mean girls watching every tv show in
high school like getting in trouble
for watching too much tv like my mom
literally told me when i was a kid like
you're gonna go blind if you sit any
closer to the tv like
that is how i became this monster and
that's why i'm literally on the podcast
we are tv fanatics as well like there's
not a show on tv we haven't seen so i
totally agree with that
yeah and like in quarantine what else
are we doing so
i what else is this book come out uh
tuesday january 26th
ah that's so exciting that is amazing
congratulations
how hard was it i feel like the idea of
writing a book
i wouldn't even know where to start yeah
i mean seriously i just taking that
first step seems so much harder than
maybe even like writing the book itself
but what was the hardest part
and maybe what was the hardest chapter
you had to write okay so like the
hardest part is legit ass writing a book
and i remember i started i had each
chapter in a google doc and of course i
started with
introduction chapter one like that's
where to start yeah and
literally my editor was like this is
really negative and i'm like oh god
so then i just decided to pick chapters
like i would go to chapter four and be
like my chapter four is my chapter on
like body image
i went to a fat camp as a kid and just
like being in the spotlight as a person
who's chubby is like a really toxic
it can be really toxic um so i just went
to chapter four
and then i was like all right now i'll
do chapter eight so i ended up skipping
around
and not writing chronologically the
hardest part was for sure
writing about like my dad dropping dead
and i actually started therapy like
around the same time i started the book
early last year
and i always thought that like i really
dealt with my dad's death in a healthy
way like it was super tragic it was a
month
into high school but you know kids are
very resilient and kids bounce back and
i think maybe if i
had lost my dad now i would have been a
wreck but kids they just
they have to adapt almost yeah and i
felt like i really handled it in a
healthy way
and i'm like i am killing it and then
like writing the book and going to
therapy at the same time i'm like oh my
god i never
dealt with my dad's death so the book i
mean everything i do
i try and have it be funny primarily and
the book is i have to say
really really funny um but there's a
couple chapters that are really earnest
and um way more vulnerable than i
thought i was going to get but i just
decided i'm like you only get one first
book let's just put it all in there
your instagram is basically corrected if
i'm wrong is like how it did
the the memes the the pages when did you
start
first and then the podcast so i started
and it's all in the book available at
girlsnowjob.com book
um but yes so i started a blog in high
school i'm no sorry college um
and it was called girl with a job and i
had gotten like this internship when i
was at nyu
and i basically started like what i
thought was going to be like the devil
wears prada of blogs
and it was not it was not but it did get
me into social media
and you know i i left the internship and
i changed the name to girl with no job
um and then started just experimenting
with a bunch of different things
instagram really took off i eventually
stopped blogging
then podcasts became really big and i
started my own podcast that i don't have
anymore but it was like my first baby
podcast it was actually like
it wasn't great quality but i had a lot
of fun it was an adventure
and then i got this show on verizon
um with my sister jackie then we took it
independent in 2018 when they canceled
the show
um so and then in 2018 when they also
canceled the show i was like damn i need
to
uh try new things and that's when i
started doing comedy and i just um
that's also in the book chapter nine um
like from like
i know exactly the page for the second
it's so funny because also people
like trolls are like you didn't write
this book i'm like [ __ ] ask me a page i
can literally recite it
i will quote i will quote myself like i
know
every single single sentence of this
book
um but yeah i started comedy just
because like
as a internet person like everyone
really does the same stuff
and if you're looking for longevity in
your business you got to be different
and you got to be cutting edge
and some people i know had started to do
live podcasts
which is cool but it's not what i wanted
to do because again i don't want to do
what everyone else does
so i'm like what about a live show and i
was very hesitant to say like stand-up
comedy because i had
no experience and there were comedians
who literally worked their whole lives
doing stand-up
and i felt like it was almost like
offensive for me to like call myself a
stand-up comedian
so i wrote like a 90-minute show and i
just started like selling tickets to
random comedy clubs
in cities that i knew like for my
instagram would be successful so i knew
new york was big for me i knew boston
chicago miami i know that these were
good cities for me
and it actually like i i literally
hopped on stage in front of 300 people
like never having done comedy in my life
and i just like talked for like an hour
okay it was iconic i have questions now
how did you remember all the the
dialogue the jokes how how did you not
that'd be blank out i mean that is so
hard so i remember i mean joan rivers is
my
favorite human being was that icon and
i've watched her documentary
a thousand times piece of work if you
haven't seen it it's so
funny and she was just like the hardest
working woman in showbiz and i'm like
how is this 82 year old woman
remembering
you know hundreds of jokes and in the
documentary she actually shows she has
huge poster board like the kind that you
used to get like
for like a science fair project yeah
yeah we taped them to the
um floor of the venue that she was in
and then she would take them with her
everywhere she goes on the jet back to
another city
place them down pick them up and i'm
like oh like cheat sheet i'm like i can
do that because i have a terrible memory
and so i didn't get huge poster board i
got like printer paper everywhere i went
and i would just write the jokes
bullet points like i knew the structure
of the show but remembering each single
joke is so hard
and i ended up like the tour was
successful and i ended up going
on tour and i did like something like 91
shows or something
wow by the 91st show i remembered it
you're like the last show i got every
last show i got it actually the very
last show i literally left out like this
huge part and i was
i was just like so excited to be done
and it was in my hometown and it was
like this huge thing it was at the
beginning theater which like real
real comedians like perform at so it was
just like so
emotional for me and i was exhausted
like i'd been on tour for two years and
i'm like
there's this great bit in the show about
um and you can actually watch a comedy
special
on amazon prime oh no we've seen it
um it's just britney spears thing it's
like kind of like the best part of the
show and i legit forgot to do it
oh no that's like oh and it's britney
spears you can't do her like that
no i know it was so disrespectful and i
got off stage and my sister
um my little sister margot came on tour
with me for most of the tour and she was
like what happened to britney spears i'm
like what do you mean i did it
she's like no you didn't and i literally
wanted to go back out and start over i
was oh
wait guys the show's not over i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding
we're gonna do all over again has there
has there been anyone that you like are
obsessed with that came to a show and
you were just freaking out
um well yeah like and i mean
sorry that i keep plugging my book but i
really did put all this stuff in my book
because i know that's what people want
to know so you guys are asking good
questions
but i hate to be like so self-promo but
yes it's in the book um
a couple shows um in la and new york uh
nikki hilton came in uh new york and
paris came in l.a and i'm just like
in love head over heels like and the
hiltons
and it was just like when when like a
celebrity recognizes you it's like
oh my god i could die like i'm maybe i'm
i'm everything
honestly no no it's still funny even
when i walk around and someone like
either
recognizes us i get really confused i
always know why i go who
they're like me listen to your show like
why isn't it such a good feeling
as a podcaster you sit in your room and
you think no one's listening
and then to see like the personification
of your work in real life is
so fulfilling it really is it is it
keeps it going because there's some days
we're just like oh my god if it's not
working and this and this and we get so
we we're really hard on each other in
the end this show
and then when someone just comes up and
goes no we really literally if one
girl's like you guys help me so much
like oh my god it's worse i gotta keep
going it's amazing and you know
podcasting is a lot harder than people
think i think
everyone you know who has a platform is
like i'm gonna do a podcast and i can
name like a hundred people who've done a
podcast
and after five or six episodes just
stopped because people are like it's an
hour a week like how much work could it
be but it is a lot of work securing
guests coming up with content doing
getting advertisers like it is no joke
and you guys are seeing that
oh my gosh so when we got into this
business we didn't even think
we thought we knew it was going to be
something we thought oh mike in front of
us
and i know there's so many layers and to
keep a show going with someone that
doesn't know how to talk or like how to
keep it interesting like what have we
not
said that someone wants to hear it's
just because people do get bored they
can't like it's
so much and the worst is when we bring
someone on or we talk about a topic that
we think is
so good and we're so excited and it just
does not get the response
segment on our show and it's like a very
unique segment and they've taken it to
their show
that they wouldn't it was it's like oh
yeah
who who who i know we should tell you
yeah but it's just like things like that
and i just i realized like
oh my god this happens so much that we
you have to be really smart to be able
to write a lot of content
every single week and then you do your
show like every single
i don't know every other day it's every
day but you know
having i don't know how people host
podcasts alone i have so much respect
for those people
um but it's also it's really nice to
have a partner and do it with your
sister but you guys can probably relate
to like
finding a rhythm like me and my sister
are both very chatty but you really
aren't you should not talk over
your podcast host which i really
struggle with like all the time um and
finding that rhythm and that flow
is so hard and honestly we've been
podcasting for like four [ __ ] years
and we're still talking over each other
and then people complain they're like
you guys are too high pitched or you
guys are too like
interrupting each other vocal fry that's
what i get i
know so i heard
that you love the housewives and i just
wanted first
oh my god and i have seen
every single real housewives show on the
planet
i mean i would love to know your
favorite
franchise you guys i feel like in like
10 years like you guys could
be on real housewives of beverly hills
you have like an interesting family life
backstory like you really could
put it out in the universe manifesting
we were talking about manifesting
earlier
it's going to happen so in general we
need a manifesto we're gonna manifest
you could definitely do it i mean i
literally got married just so i was
eligible for the real housewives of new
york and now all the women on the real
housewives of new york are not even
married not a single one of them is
married
that's a good that's a good get your own
character storyline that is the
storyline
yes well why don't you join the cast of
housewives is that your favorite
new york well the thing is it's like
i've really made my podcast is
successful for a multitude of reasons
but it's really
popular with bravo fans because we recap
every week i mean i literally right
before this
just got back from the podcast we
recapped salt lake city and oc
oh my gosh can't really be like a public
fan of the show it becomes complicated
when you like
it's weird yeah you can't be on the show
if you're like a fan of the show it has
to be like yeah because fans want you to
be like natural honestly organic yeah
or even if you would be but is that your
what would be your favorite franchise
out of all the franchises
i mean i live in new york so i want to
say new york but the new york franchise
has gone
so downhill i was having a conversation
like yesterday with someone i know she
was a queen and even like in her last
few seasons it was
kind of disgraceful but she's killing it
with skinny girl margarita
like who's winning uh her skinny girl
popcorn is so good i don't know if you
guys have it the microwave
it's like 150 calories it comes in like
a few different flavors i just like the
sea salt one
it is the best snack okay we're getting
that we're getting i think my favorite
would be luanne
she's my favorite i mean she is
hysterical
like cabaret what a character perfect
for reality tv
oh perfect there's been so many
scenarios like the falling in bushes
the like the stage man the pirates
insane parts like she and you know why
she's great
she loves the punches giovanni she knows
how to make fun of herself
and she makes money off of it like she's
actually really [ __ ] smart
she is smart and you have to be like you
gotta you gotta just let yourself mess
up on these shows because it's like
everyone is human you're gonna get [ __ ]
on for it
but when you do live anything yeah
they're a situation and i have to say
her
opening um slogan or whatever is my
favorite
which are the curtains or raise the
curtains lower the lights i'm taking
center stage in my life i love it
perfection one of my favorite things to
do is like take buzzfeed quizzes like
which housewife tag line is this because
they changed so much do you get this
of course i mean actually not to keep
plug in my book but chapter eight
which is my chapter on cancel culture is
actually titled um
it is a danielle staub quote from her
season of real housewives
you're either going to love me or hate
me there is no in between with me
do you have you ever thought about what
yours would be yes of course oh my god
a housewife fan has definitely thought
oh yeah i think we have
one but so my i like mine but it really
bothers me because i
i like when they rhyme and i'm just okay
i'll say it and then i'll tell you why
bothers me
okay i may sorry i don't like that
i may be short and round but you cannot
push me around
i just don't like that i rhyme round
with round
so i'm thinking maybe i may be short and
stout but you cannot push me around i
don't know i'm working on it
oh so good but i can't i see what you're
saying but
so good she goes oh my gosh round with
round okay
um okay i tried to think about it this
morning
right and i was like okay what is
something that i have i have a resting
[ __ ] face
um people think i'm like mean and angry
so
i thought like the only thing i bring to
the party is a resting [ __ ] face
oh that's good i like that okay i
thought of one for you too because i
knew you wouldn't have yeah i think i
have one okay guys
um ray of sunshine
but i don't mind casting a little shade
but you're not shady i mean
because you're a harry potter nerd and
you're and you're protective over your
family so this is what i thought okay
i may be a gryffindor but if you mess
with my family you'll see the ravenclaws
oh wow i mean that would have to be like
it didn't actually hit as well as that
the real housewives of harry potter but
real housewives of pogba yes i feel like
i feel like the slogans have
gone downhill though and that's 100
because i look forward to those every
new season for every single housewife
like whether it's dallas or salt lake
city i'm just like
yeah yeah when dorinda said it and think
of something like a mint in my mouth i
could be a bit fresh
what the hell does that mean
[Music]
like literally what happened to derenda
is a sharp tongue she can fall from
grace
she could have come up with something
better yeah much better oh my god oh my
god that was season 3 though too
i honestly could talk about housewives
with you all day long
we do but we just uh we really want to
thank you for coming on the show today
thank you so much for having me you are
so much fun and we'll definitely want to
hang out
when we can yes when you guys come to
new york you gotta come on the toes
sisters
just talking to sisters that would be so
much fun so we can definitely it's
easier
oh you are well come on well come on
down but plug where you can uh you find
your book your podcast
my book girl's no job the crazy
beautiful life of an instagram thirst
monster is available at anywhere you can
get books so amazon barnes and noble
indie bookstores
if you head over to girlfrinojob.combook
you can find all the links available
the podcast the morning toast is live
monday through friday 10 30 a.m eastern
time
we're available on youtube and anywhere
you can find podcasts so join us there
for a little chitchat little pop culture
little housewives little kelly's
mindless news just you know if you're
ever looking for some fun stuff head
over to the morning toast
did you say that in one breath well i've
literally been doing press for my book
like for the last two weeks i am
oh my god you didn't fully rehearse
daughter there was one that was
chef's kiss beautiful thank you so much
wow thank you claudia
we love you thank you so much for coming
on the podcast thank you so much for
having me you guys are a bunch of queens
queens bye can't wait to read your book
thank you
bye